Let us examine the connection between methods like means ends analysis and
problem reduction on one hand, and
human cognition on the other. Methods like means ends analysis,
problem reduction and even generate and test, are sometimes called weak methods.
They are weak because they make only little use of knowledge. Later on,
we'll look at strong methods that are knowledge intensive. That will demand
a lot of knowledge. The good thing about those knowledge intensive methods is,
that they will actually use knowledge about the world,
to come up with good solutions in an efficient manner. On the other hand, those
knowledge intensive methods require knowledge, which is not always available. So
humans, when they are working in a domain, in a world at which they are experts,
tend to use those knowledge intensive methods because they know a lot
about the world. But of course, you and I constantly work in worlds,
in domains in which we are not experts. When we're not an expert in our domain,
a domain that might be unfamiliar to us, then we might well go with
matters that are weak because they don't require a lot of knowledge.